When do you go at Red and stop at Green?
When you're eating of Watermelon.
Ever wondered why traffic lights are coloured the way they are?
You may probably say that Red represents danger.
Green is for safety, and who cares for Yellow!
What could be the real reason?
Let's find out!
Let's say we were to select the colours for traffic signals.
What factors should we keep in mind?
Our main focus should be the high visibility of colours,
as this is extremely important for the drivers.
It could be for a clear view from a distance
or for visibility during extreme weather conditions.
In such scenarios,
the most important signal for us to be visible is STOP.
So which colour should we choose for STOP?
Here's a spectrum chart of visible light.
Which colours are most visible to you here?
You'd probably say the ones in the middle, right?
The human eye is most sensitive to Green colour,
followed by Yellow and Blue.
So Green should be our STOP signal right?
Not so fast!
We also have to take the background into consideration here.
During the day, the colours exhibited by our surroundings
are mostly Green, Yellow, and Blue.
So, Green would not contrast well with the background.
Red is the colour that contrasts best with these colours.
Also, there is another factor that comes into play here.
When light travels a certain distance
it gets scattered and we see a blurred image.
Out of all the colours,
Red scatters the least and Violet the most.
So Red becomes a suitable choice for the STOP signal.
Now what about the other two signal lights?
These are required when we are close enough to the traffic signal.
And hence, the above mentioned factors don't matter much.
So we can use any two of Green,
Yellow or Blue for the GO and CAUTION signal.
Historically, along with the Red
these two colours were selected
and implemented by the railroads in the earlier 20th century.
And afterwards,
the same scheme was transferred for traffic signals.
You might also be surprised to find out
that the middle colour isn't Yellow, but it's Amber
which is a mix of Yellow and Orange.
So this kind of explains the probable reason
for choosing these colours.
But is it always these three colours?
Did you know that there are countries
which have chosen Blue over Green as their GO signal?
Why don't you try and find the names of these countries,
and tell us in the comments section.
Hold on!
We based our answer on how visible different colours are to us.
But, why is one colour more visible to us than the other?
What do you think?
Well, it depends majorly on our eyes.
Why?
The components of our eyes are similar to that of a camera.
We know that depending on its hardware and software,
the image we see differs from camera to camera.
Similarly, how we see things in real life
differs from person to person.
For instance, one person may see a sight like this,
while a Red and Green colourblind person
will perceive the same sight like this.
So the different components present in our eyes,
determine the way we see things.
To know more about the Components of eyes
visit the link in the description below!
Here, we just climbed the first step of the curiosity ladder with you.
Now the Kyu Box is open for you to explore.
Do share your thoughts in the comments section,
and if you learned something new today.
Do share this video with your friends and family.